[Musik]
er hat das grab meines bekommen bayern
ein video wie heute es ist jetzt
irgendwie mal wieder an der zeit ich
werde wirklich sehr so oft gefragt ich
täglich nachrichten verfassen
auf jeden fall schreiben direkt von euch
hören ja alex bitte er rad mal wieder
alter bitte mach mal wieder erwarte dass
und das irgendwie finde ich aber das
habe ich schon so oft gemacht also es
gab ja schon zwei teile
deswegen habe ich mich hingesetzt ich
bin ein sehr kreativer kopf oder
natürlich sind schon kreativ sein
schwimm und habe ein neues format
entwickelt und zwar kann ich das ganze
ich würde das nicht alleine machen ich
muss ein reeser platz für meine
mitbewohner
a2 das ganze folgendermaßen aufgebaut
ist auch euch wieder gefragt oder hab
ich gesagt ja schlägt man bild von euch
mit eurem alter und der juli hat sich
jetzt ganz viele von euch rausgesucht
und hat einen jungen und ein mädchen
oder ein mann war eine frau die
ineinander getan und ich muss halt
einfach erraten wer von den beiden
eltern ist sogar noch verstärkt
super idee ich würde sagen bei 14.000
leicht gibt davon auch nur folge mal
gucken aber darauf gehabt und jetzt
schon jetzt schon die ersten beiden
kandidaten hatten mädchen und jugend
habe ich hier fühlen zusammengefunden
job los
denn hier unten sind prozent weiß jetzt
blöd sind aber ich glaube das mädel habe
ich auch das ding ist für trainer und
zweiten fall gleich gesagt wenn ihr die
hab ich da nicht die sinne
rechtsgleichheit aus alten verwandten
des handys her genau man könnte denken
das wäre ein pärchen also dass die so
zusammen und vom alltag wird das passt
und ich würde sagen
also ich würde einfach mal sagen das
mädchen ist dies zu 16 und ersten 15 hus
gezählt
ich war 16 und 14
das mäßig mit 14 ja- und kann auch eine
schönheit gut weiß doch aus dem netz
video ich habe mich entschieden ich hab
das ford mäder ich habe das mädel nicht
arbeitet die wenig aus wie ein
informieren ein punkt ein schritt sein
wäre am ende weniger punkte hatte kriegt
eine güter steigt wir machen das heute
morgen im schlaf und so weiter geht und
natürlich mach weiter in den kommentaren
mit raten das ist ganz wichtig so zeigt
er okay die nächsten beiden gehört auch
wieder übel schwierig weg und so seit
drei jahren zusammen vielleicht wären
die anlagen zu sonnen sind süße schön
krank ist dann dieses instagram
vergleich verleiten
um ehrlich zu sein ich würde einfach mal
sagen ich würde einfach mal sagen sie
sind beide gleich alt und traten beide
der junge streifen des metalls 12 der
jugendpreis sich das mädchen nicht
wegsehen faktor aber dass sich am filter
dass ich eine chance also 480 euro im
vorjahr natürlich es geht ja darum wer
älter ist das okay extra und netto hast
du dir da hast du dir so richtig
gedanken gemacht was du so machst damit
weiter die alte bindung
also hätte schon irgendwie so ein
bisschen auswahl das ist echt schwer
jetzt ich sage eindeutig das mädel
center üblich nicht als mädels 15 und
der junge 13 junges elfen das mädchen 16
alter was hab ich künstler bin mache ich
mir gesagt reizen treibt es gab damals
nicht schaffte es aber ist es doch sich
auch nur die hälfte weiß ich dass mich
jetzt im rest des videos auch noch so
hilflos wie sie enthalten und hält den
rest war nach der hälfte der zeit ist
mich in fingern und den fingern kleiner
als die anderen es war nicht die ersten
reihen lässt 222 habe ich nicht gerecht
so ist verwarf die letzten werden mit
ansage auch komplett richtig so die
mädchen jungen um es hier
der junge ist 13 und das mädel ist 1500
prozent
warum warum junge das sieht man einfach
auf den ersten blick nicht nach es war
heißt ich will spaß ich habe die beiden
vorher noch nie gesehen weil oberste
erste die ganzen ängste die rechtlich
gesehen habe hab ich nicht ehrlich habe
ich nicht kopfüber nicht wenig gemacht
und mich jetzt lachen wenn sie mich an
mein ist schön dass sie mich nicht
falsch ich wirklich da hatte ich mich
dann einfach nur cool ich kannte was
auch die lakers dafür gibt es auf jeden
fall bislang extra punkt mit 4 2
also erstmal das mädel ist zu 100% älter
meisten auf jeden fall
warum sieht man was sieht man wird er
weiter aus die des veedels sitzt wenn
der junge 14 sitzen wird wenn sich 16 11
13 aber trotzdem will vier punkte
vier von fünf richtig dass jetzt einer
nachmachen habe beweise aber weiß gut
weil ich denken kann man doch sagen ich
muss 550 w trimesters im zweiten partie
juni steht ganz oben in der
wiederbestellung von links schlägt das
auch auf jeden fall ab und mal gucken ob
er besser ist es sich lassen doch nach
oben dafür noch ein paar checkt auf
jeden fall cnet instagram abbildet uns
morgen wieder uns jetzt nur ich wünsche
dir noch einen schönen tag hatte
die muss weg